resuelve x y nos están dando esta
igualdad tenemos 8 que multiplica el
valor absoluto de x 74 que es igual a
menos 6 que multiplica el valor absoluto
de x + 7 + 6 vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación de tal manera que nuestros
valores absolutos bueno brinquen y de
estallan y los vemos muchísimo más fácil
tendremos entonces 8
que multiplica el valor absoluto de x +
y a eso le suma una constante que
pondremos con anaranjado que será el más
todo esto será igual
- 6 que multiplica el valor absoluto de
x + 7
y que a su vez está sumado x + 6 tenemos
en verde los factores que están
multiplicando el valor absoluto y en
anaranjado tenemos las constantes vamos
entonces a hacer algo esto se ve tal vez
muy complicado pero lo que haremos y les
propongo es que despejemos primero este
valor absoluto de x + 7 para así
podernos
hacer más sencilla la vida y verán qué
bueno despejar entonces x será
rapidísimo si nosotros tenemos una
igualdad y tenemos aquí escrito que es
una igualdad para que nosotros nos
podamos deshacer
de este menos 6 valor absoluto de x + 7
lo que haremos es sumarle a este lado un
+6 valor absoluto de x + 7
ojo como esto es una igualdad debemos
hacer exactamente el mismo procedimiento
en ambos lados así es que si de este
lado hemos sumado más 6 valor absoluto
de x + 7 después del lado izquierdo
sumaremos también más 6 valor absoluto
de x + 7 vamos bien ahora vamos a pasar
las constantes del lado derecho de la
igualdad por lo que si tenemos aquí un
+4 y yo lo quiero quitar de este lado lo
queréis restar menos 4
pero como lo hice al lado izquierdo para
no afectar la igualdad también restar en
el lado derecho menos 4 vamos a poner el
signo de la igualdad
es para que nos lleva tendremos entonces
de los dos lados lo siguiente y aquí
tenemos menos seis valor absoluto de x +
7 que le estamos sumando más 6 valor al
valor absoluto de 7 por lo que estos se
eliminan
y tendremos seis menos cuatro es igual a
vamos del otro lado más 4 menos 4 se
eliminan y esto fue a propósito
recuerdan y entonces aquí sumaremos
podemos considerar este valor absoluto
de x 7 como una variable ok si tenemos 8
de algo y le sumó 6 de ese mismo algo
tendré entonces 14
de ese algo esta variable que en este
caso tenemos x + 7 considerado como
valor absoluto y el 4 y el menos 4
quedamos que ya se fue entonces pongamos
nuestro símbolo de igualdad y tendremos
entonces 14 valor absoluto de x + 7 es
igual a 2 si yo busco quitar este 14 lo
que haremos es dividir
del lado izquierdo entre 14 dado que
este 14 estaba multiplicando así es que
para quitar la multiplicación dividir si
lo hago del lado izquierdo lo haré
exactamente del lado derecho por lo que
nos quedaremos con
valor absoluto de x + 7
que será igual
214 a vos ambos números tienen como
factor común el 2 se pueden dividir
tanto el numerador como el denominador
entre 2 con eso tendremos un séptimo
voy a marcar la división aquí porque
vamos a seguir del lado derecho
ahora tenemos que entonces valor
absoluto de x 7 es igual a un séptimo
y esto solo nos da dos posibles caminos
si nosotros pensamos que tomamos el
valor absoluto de x + 7
la marca de aquí
y este número nos dará un séptimo
tenemos dos posibilidades
x 7 sea igual al valor absoluto de un
séptimo
o que x 7
fuese el valor absoluto de menos un
séptimo
y de esta manera despejar hemos x será
igual a un séptimo aquí está sumando y
para que nosotros lo podamos quitarlo
restaremos menos 77 enteros son 49
séptimos
con lo que tendremos un séptimo menos 49
séptimos menos 48 séptimos o también
podemos considerar entonces x será igual
- un séptimo
un séptimo
y quitaremos este 7 y como lo restaremos
del lado izquierdo también lo estaremos
del lado derecho 7 enteros es igual a 49
séptimos y tenemos menos un séptimo
menos 49 séptimos es igual a menos 50
de esta manera la ecuación que veíamos
complicadísima donde teníamos factores
valores absolutos y constantes al
resolverlo podemos llegar a algo tan
sencillo como que x es igual a menos 48
séptimos
o x es igual a menos 50 séptimos y esta
es nuestra respuesta